okay super blitz starting now let's do
this yeah let's play E for you fix the
layout a little bit okay so the goal is
to play super aggressively
Halloween gamuts Halloween is coming a
few days early what's today hey Siri
what's today's date
series ignoring me what does this move
it's the 25th of October I think
Halloween in six days okay I already
like this position usually I shouldn't
say usually sometimes when block
declines the Halloween white just gets a
better position
Queeny 7 tricky move so I take the night
block takes my night job g3f 5 gets
weird
I could play Queen e2 within 94 and
Bishop d3 let's make it weird
I just want a castle castling rook e1
and punished black 4 for aligning the
Queen and the King on an open file I
might even take with the take with the
pawn or with the Queen
okay Queen is bit more positional yeah
actually rook e1 will still try a nice
night discoveries whoa tog II thanks for
the bits welcome back yeah I was
hesitant to take with Queen because my
rooks not defended but if I discover and
check the King and pin the Queen to the
king and life would be good what does
this move what does this move
takes I think I'm winning everything i
takes d6 with Chuck now the Bishop's
hanging everything's hanging things are
staring in each other locks threatening
made in one which I do have to defend
against but I can take the Queen also
maybe take the b7 pawn can I take the b7
pawn and force the King yeah I force the
King to a square where I'll eventually
check and I'll win yeah I'll just win
everything I think I'm winning the Queen
by force because here I take with Chuck
Queen d7 I have this move and then I'm
expecting resignation threatening made
in one nice starts nice Halloween gambit
starts 16 moves let's keep it up hello
to everyone who's here snack attack
Frank 9 7 2 Wonka bar roof BX 1 7 etc ok
I know there's more people can only look
and play so much let me yeah let me
focus on the game I'm gonna try and
continue the super aggressive play going
for a staffer gambits
maybe later on I'll mix in some some
Dragons d3 opponent doesn't not want a
Halloween d3 is a bit passive but it's
playable ok pawns being very very
passive in d5 is a thematic approach I
want a castle Hey err Falcon
[Music]
I appreciate that oh it's castle so oh I
didn't even see my opponents raining
yeah so I shouldn't be too scared but I
should be scared of before actually
maybe let's play a five and the typical
prophylactic move hello to soaking wet
sigh opponent really wants to play be
forth on controlling it four times and
now d3 is attacked efore is looming the
kings in the center I want to play rook
e8 before anyway okay so I'm now I'll
have three attackers on d3 my life is
very good you got again not sure what
why it's gonna do yeah cuz now now the
attack against the King is it's fully
underway the Knights pinned attacked
twice rook takes b4 maybe um so many
good options let's just take on d2 and
then I'll win the Queen and maybe
eventually checkmates I can even do this
move
okay I could take everything let's take
everything and the goal is to checkmate
as quickly as possible or yeah we're
prop resignation 22 moves now the bad
starts 16 moves 22 moves I think I'll
keep I forgot about my buzzer King rule
but if I'm playing someone below 2,000
Alba's ERK but okay not this game I'll
play you for again we have a Sicilian
East six let's play G three maybe f4
would have been the most aggressive but
this can also turn aggressive at some
point
yeah after f4 it's a typical close
Sicilian ideas let's play for ideas of
h3g for eventually someday g5 start with
h3 trade mmm I'll play g4 so I have that
a file it's one of the benefits of
playing a for earlier let's play my g3
just trying to build up behind the pawns
play this move interesting to play e5 c5
and then D for coming just going for the
space crab and d4 block takes and get
some like Bishop c5 or Knight c5 so what
to do okay seven c3 could be a move
maybe c3 c3 preparing d4 if I get in d4
and I maintain a pawn on d4 then life
will be good
Tuggy
I have a location command you can type
an exclamation point location in the
chat and get your answer or I could just
tell you the answer yes I'm back in
America
hey hopefuls is also back I want to play
at six but it's weird
wait Bishop g2 whoa whoa
that's a weird emote let's play Bishop
g2 the main point is to fianchetto the
or out to unleash the rook also fiend
quatre the bishop
I wanted to play f6 hmm I have some idea
queen c19 h5 Bishop h6 just throwing
pieces at the opponents yeah I'm going
for this Black's doing stuff black built
a gun which maybe I should respect can I
play and I have six here I have six
looks interesting the idea is after it
takes takes I'm attacking the rook or
takes takes I attack the rook and the
bishop and okay black just gave away the
main defender whoa he five can I take my
takes and then Queen goes in for the
kill this should work yeah I don't think
there's any defending I mean there's
rook takes g2 there's some spite checks
but it's not gonna work Erik should be
in shadow his rook I'll block fianchetto
his rook in my territory maybe about to
fianchetto the rook on g2 it's not going
to do much
Oh how many spy checks are there maybe
King each one is most accurate I just
didn't want to deal with Queen takes F
to 93 etc okay that was nice
thirty-two moves games are gradually
increasing and move length Alison Alison
Maria in the chats shout at Alison
smooth smooth F smooth enough I'll take
that as a compliment
doom cookie thanks for your your
comments I appreciate that
Jenna fifty 92199
trying to achieve the blitz master title
have to prevent my opponent from
achieving his dreams I could play a
Cambridge Springs what to do let's just
play normal I'll play my main rapper
tour not the most aggressive but I like
this move a six
it's a pet line of mine it can turn
aggressive at some point now knight c6
important move to prevent b4 and prepare
b6 oh this is a this is an interesting
line b6 first we trade forget if I throw
in h6 I think I do do I play e5
immediately it's been a while since I've
I prepared this
okay so white I think the idea is Bishop
H 45 but this is still interesting I'm
getting the bishop hair I do want to
play e5 still yeah let's do it
p5 is a very thematic break when white
has pawns like this now we have a
reverse French mu g v g5 traps of
knights but also overextends
pros and cons let's um yeah let's trap
the Knights it's got some g5 emotes whoa
f4 so I could take on h4 and open H file
for whites
I mean I'm up a piece here I don't have
to go too crazy this is a natural move
rooks on open files have smiles now I
want a fiend hello the rook and White's
territory Wow G for the pawn storm is
real I could take on h4 with check King
f1 mm-hmm I mean does white have a
threats probably to keep pushing pawns
maybe King h8 then g5 let's start with
King eh aids g5 I just probably just
ignore it play like Bishop f5 just
developing I'm accepting that there's no
like immediate kill and just trying to
improve while giving away pawns I figure
out a six was hanging I don't think I
care that much just have to play quicker
let's play Queen Queen d7 I want to get
the bishop in Bishop g4 does this work
Bishop g4 I can also take the bishop
let's just take the bishop the bishop is
more valuable than the rook and then the
light will come in I think this is a the
best way to achieve happiness Queen h5
could be an issue so I can play this
what's a resaw maybe someone can answer
that essentially it's when you sub again
some people sub every month some people
okay wait let me let me focus I'm down
on time positions still complicated I
didn't really want to trade Queens but I
think I have to explain I see for going
after e3
how does white defend King f2 rook a1
okay let's play h5 cementing the bishop
king of two still expected no I want to
see and kettle the night to get to d3
yeah I can pre move 93 hmm hard to break
through play rook hey play this move not
sure what to do
Lee things are falling apart and time is
very low okay I have to focus focus
focus
I gave away too many things
now I'm suffering should f5 never okay
6mm so risky move oh that was terrible
move why'd I do that
oh not good I have any threats
let's play this this is really bad
seven seconds things are crumbling okay
something here hmm yeah this is a sad
finish just praying for stalemate
so sad I got careless I've spent too
much time in in moments where I
should've moved quicker but that's what
happens can you do fewer challenges like
if you lose an X game you do 10 push-ups
um yeah that's an interesting idea maybe
if I do that enough times I'll become
jacked but I have a workout like earlier
today
okay let's desert because I'm tilted my
work out earlier today involved a lot of
push-ups so now my arms are sore but
maybe it would incentivize me not to
lose d4 what's d4 um I could play c6
looks interesting mmm okay this is a
very weird opening interesting paw
information in the center let's just
continue developing
that looks reasonable have to remember
that I bizerta that's important piece of
information okay I want to take on d5
maybe I should okay let's take first I
should Castle soon
how many pawns on my down ooh a 4 a 4 is
interesting if my takes and I take on e
2 and force my opponent to bonk loud
let's take I'll win d5 this pawn is
probably untaken ball cuz stuff on
e-file happens okay so I'm only down on
time material is somehow equal d4 is
attacked let's just continue improving I
have most important things on the light
squares so the bishop is pretty pretty
sad g4 may be expected but they're
behind the pawn on Queen b3 targeting
some pressure points okay g7 is
defending but I mean can I take on d4
takes takes takes
yada-yada let's do it
33 seconds Oh maybe that was a bad
decision but it's complicated some ideas
after rook takes d4 I just take a lot of
white to take on g7 and then hope
everything works out okay this looks
very reasonable now see three well I
have a free rook okay still free rook
and mate next move that worked out guess
in hindsight III led to the quickest win
two free rooks
is there another free ruck maybe there
was
gmt-- can t shadow 2gm can t a so GM can
t hello streamer said something about
being strong let's play e for again
today is an e for stream no matter how
strong you are you can always get
stronger by doing push-ups opponent
offline but it says online what when I
hover over his name it's a green dot but
here it's a black dot ok quickest win
condolences to my opponents 13 points
fighting for first place perching the
halfway points my favourite opening yeah
is is a London I have I probably have a
list of like 5 to 10 favourite openings
depending on the situation
oh he's logged in but not viewing the
game Oh
sometimes that happens to me worried
like it starts the game in the new tab
and then I don't realize and it's sad ok
so we have another Queen's Gambit oh
maybe I should have played a Budapest
okay let's at least play something a bit
different g3 I'll take free pawn this is
a sharp line ideas to just defend the
pawn and be up upon a3 was maybe a mouse
slip usually white should play for but
maybe it was intended okay so usually
black does this stuff white tries to
brag about the center it's my a5 so the
Queen usually likes to go to b6 but then
d5 is scary
b4 is a move queen c8 let's play Queen
CA just want to do stuff I've a little
less space but I still have squares to
maneuver Queen c2
mm-mean c5 is thematic oh but doesn't
work so I Bishop a6 may be preparing c5
may be preparing b4 or two before B
three ideas play rook b8 getting off the
diagonal sometimes that's relevant
I can play e5 f4 is coming so I should
do something I'll play e5 typical move
if I might comes to e5 then maybe
someday I can come to d3 and cause
mayhem d5 could play Knight c5 here the
same idea Knight e3 so nice it's a nice
orifice in White's territory if white
takes and I'm happy to have the bishop
hair f4 might come it's still sharp d6
unexpected but it's kind of a tactic can
I take with the rook think I can take
with the rook I just leave the night
hanging for a move but after it takes
takes takes takes life is good
absurd not too much what's up with you
thanks for subbing for 2 months yeah
White's is uh it's probably realizing
that he just lost another pawn no I'm
not two pawns and the fun time is that a
giraffe mug uh yeah you can see the
giraffe right it even says giraffe as a
picture of giraffe along with average
ref it seems a bit redundant ok f2 is
not a free pawn because the Queen
defends before is interesting but it's
just to improve I guess yeah the smash
is coming
tuner for the resub for four months
should I take it yeah let's take it
okay the rook needs a better square Oh
put some pressure on the pawn I could
play before ooh I have Lila made in one
threats threatening me than one
well the attack is actually kind of
quick I was nice the tea was nice to me
it was nice still in fourth place trying
to catch up and heal the wound from that
one loss dragon mutts let's play a let's
play a dragon accelerated in no let's
play normal dragon okay I can still play
a dragon structure waiting for a white
to play d4 play I have six first usually
the rule is you should develop the
kingside and then later the Queen side
so c3 and completely 5/5 is I think a
typical move thanks tog II see em
usually I mean like in terms of chess
that means candidate master but what
beautiful candidate master are you
referring to not h5 is interesting we
might get the Kings Indian structure if
d5 here and then eventually f5 this is a
bit more positional but I still want to
play aggressively
it's my bishop she lets play Issa or h6
first I want to play Bishop e6 and not
worry about Knight g5 or Bishop g5 play
b6 again just a matter of improving
Queen will go to c7 just completing the
ideal setup eventually like this stuff
metaphor immediately but I can't be
kicked cuz when I win h3 might be free
thanks for the bits might be free might
might happen next move
probably not a great square for the
night though against this structure well
I play viewers um well I I could be
playing a viewer right now I don't know
he might be watching my stream you can
join the tournament oh dude my stream
just died no my stream just died
what happened reconnecting okay I deeply
apologize for that I think I'm back
also a kd7 with a thousand bits sorry
for that brief interruption that was a
little bit strange
oh the bit notification didn't show up
because I was probably still
disconnected and Xebec on also thanks
for subbing okay I didn't lose too much
time but I am down that time however I
like my position oh there we go
notifications yeah apologies again I
would imagine twitch will break that up
into breaks it up into two separate
streams which means if I post this on
youtube in the future
gonna have to do some editing so a
threat I don't feel so threatened that's
by g5
if anyone's being threatened it should
be white I would like to bring the Queen
to f6 and then threaten this just about
creating tactics Queen f6 Knight g4 I'll
do it anyway I might take on g4 ooh and
tactic is working I think I can take off
to now okay white collapsed and just a
few moves there Wow abrupt ending 20
moves in second place Billy the Kid
chest
winning everything have to be careful
trying to catch up maybe I should be
zerk if I get the right opponents no
there's still time
I won't beserk but I'll play
aggressively let's play play it to
Knights attack aggressive approach
against the French yeah this line black
grab space but light gets a decent setup
at six what is f6 maybe e5 maybe c3
that's why c3 want to open the position
cuz blacks a bit slow to develop it's
hard to open things up you should
probably go for f4 soon I'll play this
threatening Queen eh v g6 I can take
also g6 right away play d3 I want to
play f4 still might be free with more
bits now I left for okay lots of content
shinned castling queenside while trying
to run away could take do I take with
hmm take once take again not sure if I'm
getting like so much the center is
closed but it's going to be sharp
want to attack on the Kings side bring
the knight back to f3 the eventual goal
is to play b4 open up some lines okay
trade if takes with pawn Bishop g5 would
be nice here maybe I can leave the
tension start with rook b1
yeah now I can take and have a nice
outpost the knife the knife is alive on
f5 that's a move let's play b4 so it's
hard for a black to open either of these
files but we might just have an endgame
I could take multiple ponds and take on
e5 all these pawns are hanging
threatening to take on c5 with check now
I think I'll take here Queen f7 I have
Brooke out 5 because I don't want to get
mated
yeah Queen f7 is a mate in one to three
threats I could take another pawn I feel
like there's a lot of options here maybe
just rook b5 pile up on b7 if b6 and I
have C 5 C 5 can also be explosive okay
here I could take and trade a little bit
can take on h5 let's take on h5 the time
has come to be greedy and win more pawns
g5 is hanging I might take on b7 at some
points or I might just win more pawns
I feel so greedy but so satisfied how
many pawns on my up chip I need to count
okay let's just trade Queens and convert
the endgame cuz I'm down on time oh no
Queen trade that's why a four have to
use my pawns this rook is pinned
can be a treasonable let's play this I
want to play this in this
and now let's straight Queens ooh
forgot about that okay I'll just take on
d4 and play rook be to be safe I want to
play rook d7 soon be six a five Hey
greed is good is it in the chat it was a
very fitting username for this game
let's play c5 just overloading the the
pinned upon King c8 some move and then I
take this pawn kind of close to meet
threatening mate in one
okay now I win the rook okay
took some work one point behind first
place still have a streak playing ich
nick d6 let's play Bishop c4 I was like
on the verge of falling asleep last
night and this just came to mind Bishop
c4 against appears idea of playing early
Queen e2 can I just play this takes
takes look looks too fun and it fits a
the stream title super aggressive chess
that's probably just dubious for me
though
yeah I'm just sucking a piece the
problem is queen g6 comes but maybe it's
not such a tragedy I'm just going to be
down a piece
let's play d3 but all have pawns to
pawns for a piece blacks King is on g8
maybe I could play c3 and somehow
checkmates also maybe I'll win Connect
four with the diagonal pawn chain
I guess all pond chains are diagonal but
not all connect four is our diagonal
Knight b6 f4 hmm my knight is feeling
some heat
what should you there's e5 c5 is
interesting maybe I should just retreats
[Music]
maybe I'll be greedy
take another free pawn I should also
develop starting slowly
I guess King each one's not a
development move but it's a safe place
for the King retreat the knight avoiding
trades I'm just gonna pretend that I'm
not down a piece and then life will be
okay I mean I really don't have any
weaknesses position is solid let's play
a four I want to do this and win the
pawn a five okay Knight be free coming
oh I have the free nights I was so
fixated on Knight be free which I don't
even know if I want to play anymore why
did I not take that free night okay
let's let's do something else the other
night doesn't belong on b3 anyway Knight
c4 bit more aggressive
b5 hmm I'm still slow playing I don't
want to make like too many commitments
until I'm ready ooh
this move is tricky is that the night
moves I have Queenie for winning the
rook but then there's a Chi 3 could get
messy but should be fine for me
and if takes takes a Knights pinned by
the rook so tricky situation for black
that's probably the best move I could
take yeah let's take so I'm not winning
anything but I still have pawns still
have not lost a single pawn I wanna play
Knight f3 and still pretend that I'm not
down the piece there's East 6 here u 6
looks fancy but also overextending lady
4 mm or else Queen g3 I'll play Queen g3
looks like the most solid approach
covering h3 just in case some sacs
happen you know the Queen Queen is
actually okay on each - I think maybe
someday g4 also Knight f3 still
improvement moves to make can we could
trade rooks there's some tricks he 7e 6
wins something I'm up on time time is
very relevant probably be the the key to
winning this game clayji for now
let's put the knight on d4 what to do
not sure about a five no let's play c3
looks solid free pawn not actually free
because there's rook b8
but that's okay play g5 it's an e mode
action take that okay this is scary
defend this is very scary I won't play
rook F - there's a trap in the end
Knight takes e5 Bishop D for winning the
Knights also blacks about to flag C
sevens a bit weak or on a5 is a bit weak
there we go okay back to treatments as a
close game still chasing first place
I've not been in first place as this
tournament Sun F is now leading also has
a pretty impressive streak have to
consider buzzer King soon not too much
time left
Matt game I just played went full
distance play The Dude's gambit what's a
dude's gambit never heard of that maybe
I'll play a gambit
I still want to play a budapest taking a
while to start a game maybe it's waiting
for Sun F to finish there you go okay as
irking time do the pest time or London
time Budapest
let's go with a pest declined I like the
structure
let's castle
I'll go with a plan B for B for my g4
and that's actually like impossible for
a white to defend F to successfully now
I have a bishop let's play this move so
I mop up on let's play a5 preventing B
for Bishop a7 I guess some Bishop g4
ideas ideas also just bringing the
knight to f6 let's start with Bishop g4
sometimes before you play aggressively
you have to develop your pieces
important rule
I could take now takes Queen h4 or let's
do it take away White's castling rights
thinking about f5 yeah its aggressive
idea after it takes to play e4 you just
break through open the center and get to
the king let's play Knight c5 fighting
for efore Knight b5 I could take first
attack the bishop and then probably play
Bishop b6 even 93 can't find with this
ok rooks are fort and queen d4 Queen D
for anything better
si I have to accept that I'm losing a
rook also I deserve so I should move
faster let's just do this
ooh now Queen D for almost Windsor rook
but there's Keaney too and now he for
now this looks pretty good
the king is in the eye of the hurricane
let's take enough three and do stuff
with the pieces I'm not seeing mates
over 22 seconds now I'm threatening
threatening Rogoff to threatening
Queenie for hmm start with Queenie for
the rooks hanging on g1 got - okay
should do the job I still have to meet
in time plenty of time 15 seconds 23 but
where is the mate just take a pawn first
and take more pawns - watch out for
stalemate tricks opponents gonna try the
rosin trap there we go okay
another victory in the back so on f is
running away oh but it didn't update my
score okay that berserk helped so I'm
within one point 11 minutes left it's
going to be a close finish
Shawn F is about to win another game not
what I want to see so I should be zürich
again who maybe I shouldn't I'm not
gonna berserk I'll say berserk King for
the finish just to play quickly though
this Queen takes like I've seen this
movie before Queen takes this looks
reasonable play Bishop d6 I'm up a pawn
also up a bishop okay this is what I
needed
opponents not gonna resign though
casting is illegal I'll keep the bishop
or should I just take the Knights let's
keep the bishop as king it oh that's
annoying
um why why is this annoying let's take
here make that night go away and then
let's just develop I'm up a piece no
need to overthink things clicking our
fates
maybe I'll fee and hello my king and
just connect the rooks
also play g4 and g4 is annoying threats
what to do when g4 is very annoying I
have this move let's do that move
threatening f4
I'll bring the rook into play yeah
playing passively but okay here's a
something rook takes f7 light winds upon
but I'm still up a piece and IG 595 I
can take it
maybe six not the best technique but I'm
kind of getting the job done once a draw
no draw but how do I actually make
progress to bring my knight to f6
probably then use my king each five
coming or a g5 coming ooh
tricky let's play this oh this is not
good
I just mess this up oh no oh this is not
good at all yeah c4 okay I'm gonna put
the Bishop on e7 stopping f5 oh this is
really not what I wanted I might end up
losing this
there we go okay that's what I needed
it's really what I needed the fork
nights has come to the rescue
now let's just take this make things
very simple run to be three Bishop here
check oh that didn't do much but that's
okay see for coming
28 seconds is enough time son F why am i
struggling let's not give away the
bishop just yet okay hey I have the lead
and so on a slawsa streak and there's
time for probably one more game so let's
not beserk let's play a London I'm gonna
just try and keep the cleanliness that
last game was very messy though it's
very messy its bits its bone the specks
thanks might be free Oh Queen d2 or no
probably the smooth
yeah this is a very pleasant structure
and it bodes well for playing
aggressively especially when black
castles I could play g4g for King b1
start with King b1 I'm not in much rush
now g4 I want to play g5 can probably
take and play h5 even at 4 first h5
coming soon
maybe e4 hey maybe I can get all the
pawns for the fourth rank the h5 the g5
it gets weird I still want to play e4
yeah e4 Connect four more bits thanks
Sagi g6 is weak so the idea is Queen
here and then eventually Queen g6 block
will probably play Queen e8 at some
points I can do stuff with pawns this
looks promising though but what sort of
stuff with pawns takes
start with this thinking of takes and
takes if takes and takes and takes takes
takes Queen g6 and end if efore I take
with check okay so there's two about two
and a half minutes left in the
tournament should be enough time for
this game to finish yeah so here I take
and then Queen III and Queen g5 and now
maybe just just Queen e5 2 now let's
take and then win pawns do I start with
hmm play b3 looks weird but I didn't
want their up to come to yet even though
it still does but the Knights restricted
now I want to bring my knight in
probably to g3 and then rook f1 now
Queen g7 forces no Queen g7 hangs our
rook that's nice so let's play h6 giving
the Queen some square stopping rook g7
and now I want to play Queen e5 check 25
checkers or winning threats because King
G at age 7 now I bring the knight in
threatening to h5 also burakov won a
multi-purpose night hmm I guess I can
play this
Oh Sun ass has passed me so I need to
win this game I can't have the scheme go
until the very end
Oh am I just winning I think I'm just
winning hey I won back to tournament so
Sun f means to win oh and Sun F is
playing and is on the verge of winning
pairings are closed
let's watch Sun off there is one minute
left
please okay
these whites survived for one minute no
you're losing but don't resign no don't
reside don't resign run out your time
forty seconds no I didn't win the
tournaments
really oh I wait Oh son F was not on a
streak so I think I won the tournament
what's going on is this the right score
refresh is the right score so son F only
got two points probably should've is
Ertz there's bits might be free Thanks
and also nerds tits keys thanks the
tournament is where is it timer oh it's
done okay
was it close finish I played yesterday
yesterday was not a close finish but
today was a close finish cool lost out
one game almost cost me had some messy
games had some fun games - I think soggy
for the bits yeah that last game some
fun pong play so I'll probably put this
on youtube
oh it's another name weight column media
thanks for the bits so for the YouTube
people watching in the future I think
I'll call this super aggressive chess in
the super blitz arena part 2 there's
something along those lines
part 1 was yesterday which I plan on
uploading tomorrow so for future people
on YouTube hope you enjoy that I'll see
you in the future